The answer is you suck and I look
forward to you sucking again
in season two and I look forward to
collecting
some more trophies
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new thor 4 love and
thunder avengers 5 video chris hemsworth
just confirmed some big details about
the future of thor
in the mcu trash talking everyone so
we'll break it all down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway too
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which other
big movies you want thor to cross over
into during marble phase 4
in marvel phase 5. so just starting with
the big stuff first number five
chris hemsworth revealed that he would
be continuing as
thor in the mcu after thor for love and
thunder so everybody wipe your foreheads
sigh of relief he's not going anywhere
everyone start getting hyped up for
revengers 5 but his exact quote about
coming back for more marvel movies and
more thor movies reads like this
and this is him responding to a question
in an interview recently asking him if
thor 4 love and thunder would be his
last marvel movie and if they're going
to kill the character off
or if thor's going to retire like
captain america the big twist at
avengers end game where he fades into
the background before avengers secret
wars
so chris hemsworth said and it reads
like he was screaming when he was saying
this he said are you crazy
i'm not going into any retirement period
as he's laughing while saying this
thor is far too young for that he's only
1500 years old it is definitely not a
film that i say goodbye to this brand
at least i hope so so when he says he
hopes so quote unquote that's him just
joking about his new contract
in the political business stuff behind
the scenes for more marvel movies like
he hopes that all that stuff goes well
because at this point marvel does have
to pay him way more money per movie
even though disney does have infinite
money that was one of the reasons why
they were looking for ways to move
iron man into the background heading
into marvel phase four they were having
to pay robert downey jr so much money
his salary on avengers infinity war and
avengers endgame
was actually enough money to make a
whole other marvel movie by itself
and just for reference chris hemsworth
and the other a-list avengers characters
besides robert downey jr each earned
about 20 million dollars
for just avengers end game that doesn't
include their salary for avengers
infinity war i think it was also about
20 million dollars for infinity war as
well
and if you didn't know he is correct
thor really is only about 1500 years old
in present day of the mcu give or take
a few years time moves a little bit
differently for them when they're that
old
according to loki in thor the dark world
just normal asgardians not the ones who
are part of their pantheon just the
regular ones live for up to 5 000 years
thor odin even loki who's actually a
frost giant
all have those extra cosmic powers
because of their bloodline which allows
them to live potentially even
longer if they're not killed in battle
like in the comics
thor lives for millions of years just
like odin once he gets the odin force
he almost lives long enough to see the
heat death of the universe
but number four when chris hemsworth
said that he's not saying goodbye to the
thor
brand quote unquote the brand he's
talking about the thor
movies now that doesn't confirm that
they're going to be doing thor 5 because
if they did it wouldn't happen for
several years
till well after avengers 5. he's mostly
talking about the bigger thor related
movies like avengers 5 or if you want to
make the revengers joke revengers 5.
potential crossover movies like a
reverse thor ragnarok situation where
thor's the main character
in someone else's solo movie like
fantastic four
sequels or the silver surfer movie
silver surfer and galactus have spent a
lot of time crossing over with thor in
marvel comics and the future of the mcu
per kevin feige is in the multiverse and
in space with big cosmic threats that's
why nick fury moved to that sword space
station in the spider-man far from home
post credits
because the next big threat is from
outer space in thor is one of their og
most powerful cosmic avengers character
so of course it makes sense that he's
involved with the future of the cosmic
mcu movies
plus you kind of need to have a
transition from the old avengers team to
the new roster with a couple of core
original characters returning in
avengers 5 to round
out the cast and serve as a foundation
for that new avengers team
no joke right now the two most important
avengers characters that marvel has
coming back
are thor and spider-man thor has seen
thousands of years worth of cosmic
history so he knows a lot more about
what's coming for them in avengers 5
these other big cosmic threats that the
avengers haven't learned about yet
even though he mostly pretends to be
stupid so people will like him more he
just has all this knowledge that they
haven't encountered yet because he's
been around for so long even though he
hasn't gone full-blown
king thor yet or old man thor spider-man
is important for several other reasons
mostly because he along with superman
and batman is one of the top three
most popular best-selling comic book
characters of all
time in the real world everyone around
the world who doesn't read comic books
or doesn't care about comic book movies
still knows who spider-man is if you
show them a picture they say oh that's
spider-man
within the story of the mcu though as
it's evolving he was also there for
everything that happened before
avengers end game in the infinity
gauntlet and we are still watching him
take the mantle of iron man that he
passed down to him that was what
spider-man far from home was all about
i'll talk more about spider-man and
marvel phase 4 and avengers
5 when they start filming spider-man 3
later this year there'll be a lot of
spider-man stuff happening for the rest
of the year
this video is mostly supposed to be
about thor so three just in terms of how
many new movies thor would be in
after thor 4 love and thunder it'll
probably be a nick fury situation where
he does a couple bigger ones like he's
the main character in avengers 5 because
he's one of the core avengers
and he does at least one other big
crossover movie where he's the main
character
and then on top of that he gets a couple
smaller cameos in the other movies to
help tie things together
like his cameo at the end of the doctor
strange post credit scene
okay well listen good luck with that and
don't forget your umbrella oh can't you
just magic it over to me
oh i think we both know even this wizard
can't do that
then you also have marvel's disney plus
loki series it would be weird if he
didn't appear in that at some point
they're still filming it right now i'll
do more videos about it when they get
ready to release the trailer it won't
premiere till
next spring in 2021 but i do believe
that it'll run for multiple seasons so
it'll be really crazy really weird
everybody loves loki so it'll be a lot
of fun
then vin diesel accidentally already
confirmed that the guardians of the
galaxy would appear in thor 4 love and
thunder
and that thor conversely would appear in
guardians of the galaxy 3.
thor will also the director talk to me
about
how thor will incorporate some of the
guardians of the galaxy which would be
very interesting nobody knows but maybe
i shouldn't have said anything
remember originally guardians 3 would
have been released before
thor 4. it was actually supposed to be
released this year but there were a
number of reasons why that didn't happen
so we would have seen them follow up on
this thor scene from the avengers end
game ending with thor still being fat
thor
but hitching a ride with them for more
adventure before
thor ford picked up and then that would
have been the end of it guardians 3 was
originally just meant to be its own
thing with just that little thor moment
and then all the guardians characters go
their separate ways
mostly at the end of that movie because
james gunn revealed it is the last movie
with that particular roster of guardians
it's not the end of the guardians it's
just the end of that roster of guardians
so when they come back in a future
space-based marvel movie like avengers 5
or some other big crossover movie like
the captain marvel movies or fantastic
four or silver surfer it'd be a
different roster of guardians
early prediction too we don't know which
movie is going to happen in yet but
there will probably be a thor galactus
and silver surfer scene at some point
after those two characters debut but
that probably won't happen
in the first new marvel fantastic four
reboot movie
they'll probably just have galactus
silver surfer easter eggs like some
vague broad implication of future
avengers marvel threats from space
coming for earth
like a version of the original avengers
post credit scene where thanos shows his
face just letting you know that the
infinity gauntlet the infinity saga
is going to be the big story in number
one the biggest stuff returning thor
means for thor 4
love and thunder because they're getting
ready to film that right now is
obviously the jane foster thor will not
be replacing
thor odin's son in the mcu as the main
version of thor
i think a lot of people had questions
about that after the marvel phase 4
comic con panel last year after the
reveal that part of the plot of thor 4
would be the mighty thor comic book
story where jane foster becomes a
version of thor
so right now it just sounds like jane
foster thor will just be a thing
for this one movie briefly and then
maybe they bring her back or that
version of the character back for
avengers secret wars for some big
multiverse twist depending on what
happens to jane foster at the end of
thor 4.
christian bale is still going to be the
villain thank you very much tessa
thompson for accidentally revealing that
i don't think she was supposed to do
that
they haven't completely confirmed who
his villain is going to be but right now
everyone believes it's going to be a
version of gore the god butcher since
there are only a handful of cosmic level
marvel villains from the thor comics
that they haven't done yet
they're also big enough to be a threat
for thor thor also still has
stormbreaker and he's still worthy so
the only way jane foster is wielding
mjolnir is if they reforge the broken
pieces of the one from the main universe
that hella destroyed
or if we're talking about hardcore
multiverse and marvel phase 4 movies
they use a mjolnir from another universe
but let me know in the comments
just besides guardians of the galaxy 3
which other solo movies do you want to
see thor cross over into after
thor 4. there will be more marvel
trailers later this year we'll probably
get the first marvel eternals trailer
with the black widow movie in november
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see all those
videos when i post them
but everyone click here for my black
panther 2 chadwick boseman video
and click here for the boys season 2
episode 4 video with a bunch of marvel
easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!